it's still kind of a matter of working
out like the technical kinks
yes you and me both but i think we're in
what i would call relatively good shape
right now
sweet now i am able to see your green
screen it's sort of a peak behind the
curtain i guess we could say
yeah yeah you get a kind of a a very
rare view of
what what it looks like because on my
screen i just have like a transparent
background right um but
yeah i used to not use a green screen
and then
a few months ago i had moved in with
some other chess players
and there was a green screen just
sitting in the closet and figured why
not use it
so are you in a sort of chess house now
is that the deal
yeah so have you heard of the the chess
bras who hasn't
okay so yeah i moved in with um in april
right last year and we're we still keep
our like separate brands
yeah but um it was great kind of moving
into their apartment because they
already have like a great
streaming setup all equipment and on
april 1st of last year i i
posted on twitter i was moving into the
chassis apartments
and no one believed me because it was
april fool's day but
um but it's worked out great that's
great so
i'm sure it's wild there um well
recently they're more based in canada so
recently i've had the whole place myself
but it's incredible when they're in town
with sometimes chess a lot of chess
uh the celebrities will come over uh
yasser's been been over many times
so wow it's nice place to be in st louis
what's like the big uh controversy right
now
in the chess world is there one that's
being dealt with right now
um there there's always drama going on
in especially in like the online chess
community
uh but it usually blows over over the
course of like couple weeks
um if you if you asked this like a month
or two ago
there were just so many so many
different things happening so many
controversies
really um but all it seems like a lot of
them have have kind of blown over
um i mean there's been this huge kind of
boom
on i'm sure you know like on on twitch
with the
chess category and um
i think the at least a major chess
platforms are kind of
are competing to try and get more more
audience
and uh there is a point uh i think it
was a month ago
magnus carlson streamed on twitch
where he he's kind of um he works with
the site chess 24
right and he streamed on chesstalk.com
but made it appear that is that kind of
that he was playing on chess 24 where he
used their same kind of overlay and same
kind of stream design
um it was kind of just like a troll move
and it sparked a lot of discussion for a
few days
wow that's uh and what would be the
point of doing that is it
just trolling um i don't know if anyone
really knows
uh i think during his stream he
mentioned he
he wanted to play on chess.com for one
day just to get a higher rating
than hikaru who has like the highest
rating on chess.com
and he played for at least six or seven
hours non-stop
and got like maybe 50 or 100 points
short and then
and just kind of gave up um has there
been like
i'm trying to think of the right way to
phrase this there it seems that with the
recent chess boom some people have more
hit the streaming lottery than others so
to speak
is there resentment in the chess
community
as to who has been
sort of benefiting more from the
coronavirus chest boom than others
that's an interesting question um i
there there's always like tensions
sometimes between certain streamers
um but i think overall at least
everyone who who i talked to and
across at least on like the streamers on
on twitch
are are usually quite supportive of
supportive of one another
and there's always like raids kind of
happening like
um with most streamers when they end
their stream they'll send a raid to
another stream
of course um and recently there's been a
lot more collaborations
where streamers are organizing matches
against each other or
just kind of more kind of casual
sessions to answer questions with with
viewers
so i think overall it's been more
positive
than any sort of like negativity
that's interesting yeah cause a bunch of
people told me you know i come from the
political space which is so toxic in
every way and i got a bunch of messages
from people saying
oh online chess is just as toxic like if
you're looking to get out of toxic the
last thing you want to get in on is
online chess but
my experience and even what you're
describing doesn't sound so bad
yeah i think um i mean especially in
online gaming
there's always going to be some toxicity
um in different communities but
um at least from my experience like the
the
vast majority of people are just here to
learn the game
to kind of use it as some form of escape
from right maybe more more real world
problems
so um so i try and keep it that way at
least on my stream
to have a more more kind of positive
wholesome view on things are you taking
a position
on hassan versus destiny
ah i've so i i'll admit i have not
followed either streamer so closely okay
the the first time i heard of destiny
was when he played in your
arena tournaments oh no way and i i was
following some of his games
um and then i think he wanted to play
you but you turned down the match i
don't know if that's far
oh that i'm not aware of if that's a
that's a completely false rumor as far
as i'm concerned
um yeah i've
it was a few months ago but i i assumed
that
uh like after after the tournament he
tried to send you a challenge but maybe
oh okay that may be that maybe after
things get so crazy after the tournament
i usually get like 30 challenges
that it's completely plausible it's
entirely possible i would even
say that that happened and i just didn't
see it no and i'm not taking a position
on it anyway
in fact it's better that you not even
know that there is a hassan versus
destiny thing i would be
i would prefer to be in that boat
actually
yeah no it's nice kind of being in in my
own bubble where i i don't have to
get get so wrapped up in the these these
random uh
random rivalries but um i wanted to
congratulate you for
for getting invited to this vlog champs
too
oh thank you it's going to be yeah
listen i
i need you to be brutally honest with me
here is it conceivable
that i just am not going to really get
any better at chess because we i i
think you know there's certainly a
possibility here
that uh you know it's like my memory
seems
fine when it comes to political stuff
new stuff you know i remember
it what would seem to be the type of
memory that would be useful in chess
but when it comes to chess i i'm
definitely having a problem here and
even
remembering just avoiding basic opening
problems you know so i'm wondering if
maybe there's a defect where chess may
just not be my thing
well it's definitely more difficult to
learn when you're
you're an adult i mean this is
and this is the case with any field not
just chess but any language
when you're learning any new skill as an
adult you're not going to be learning it
as quickly as if you were like a kid
sure um
but with that said that's not going to
stop you from still getting better
and and working on your weaknesses right
um
and i've i've worked with many adult
students over the years and it's still
possible
to make big improvements you but you do
need to put in the time and the hard
work
and and spend spend time on a consistent
basis
uh like playing longer games solving
solving exercises
and um i mean these sort of kind of like
coaching sessions
they should really just be kind of a
supplement to kind of the main work that
you're putting in
right i need to understand the main work
it's the main work
long games puzzles studying strategy etc
because i want to be prepared for this
thing
sure yeah and at your level like you you
definitely want to focus
on the types of things that will bring
you the most
kind of value with the least amount of
work like this whole 80 20 principle
yeah um i i've looked at some of like
your recent games too
and kind of got a sense of there's some
ugly stuff and that's he fixed
no i i saw i saw um
but at your level and then it seems like
for most of the participants
in pogchamps what determines most games
are blunders and um and just tactics
right and then also time management
which is sometimes overlooked
where um like when you play pogchamps
i'm pretty sure the last one
i would imagine this next one too will
be
um some kind of like 10-minute chess
with some increments i believe
so yeah so what you'll want to do is
uh is get used to that time control and
get used to
to having just that amount of time on
the clock where
it's enough time to maybe slow down
during like the critical moments
or when the position gets complicated
but then
if there's a moment where you have like
maybe an easy decision to make
or it's not so critical you'll you'll
want to be able to identify when you can
when you can play quickly
right and kind of play low-risk chess
that makes perfect sense to me
theoretically in the moment obviously
it's hard to identify the moments
sometimes
right right yeah but like based on the
games i saw that you play like
i'd say the overwhelming majority are uh
are based off like one move tactics
or um or just careless blunders like he
hated one for example yep yep then
that's that's one of my specialties in
fact
yeah so should we i i sent eric a game
from today where you know my instinct
was that i was
very very close to to just dominating
and i ended up getting mated before i
was able to put anything together and i
deliberately didn't look
at an analysis board because i knew we
would be going over
it so i don't know if we want to want to
look at that yeah definitely uh
i just invited you to like a shared uh
leachate study
okay which if you beautiful
uh if you can join i see you're already
in yeah
um i also i do want to thank uh there's
a very popular chess streamer
grandmaster daniel nerditsky who i
believe is another coach
for uh for pogchamps uh he just sent a
raid with
close to 3000 people so i want to thank
him for that
but um if you get a chance to work with
him he has like a
ton of chest knowledge yeah it doesn't
it doesn't seem as though i've been
assigned
that particular coach but there's you
know i i think uh
you we're we're gonna persevere anyway
okay if you're not assigned to daniel
then you have to be careful against like
who daniel's coaching
ah because he has a very good kind of
ability to predict
what what you could do in the opening
and
uh there is a moment in the previous pog
champs where he
basically predicted the full game of
xqc losing in six moves okay see that i
want to avoid yeah
right see this is a this is a bigger
question which is if i am
if if it's clear from the lessons what
i'm working on
then someone can just prepare against
that right so i need to have a
essentially a shadow
training regimen yeah and that's an
interesting point i think it's
completely fine
especially with like the live stream
lessons to like publicly work
on like middle game end game strategy
but when it comes to openings those are
are that's one stage where
sometimes you want to be a bit more
secretive right um
because if i'm not mistaken what what uh
daniel would do
uh and during the last pog champs he
would watch
these kind of lesson streams of
of of the coaches teaching the the
participants
and then just kind of monitor what
openings were being taught
wow and then then secretly prepare his
his students with some some
vicious weapons right well hopefully
i'll get the same preparation
yeah and i'm happy to like like
especially off stream just just kind of
send you some uh
some some secret preparation um
especially when it's it's specialized
for for one opponent
um and this is something to keep in mind
um especially when you know
who you're going to play beforehand
right because with most of the pogchamp
matches
you know a few days before who you'll
play what color you'll be
usually actually you'll have both colors
um
and then you can you can usually see
what they're playing online and get a
sense of what to expect
yeah i re i want to avoid a huge
embarrassment because if
like for example if i fall for scholars
mate i don't think elizabeth warren is
coming on my show again
oh yeah you have to be careful with that
for sure definitely
all right well yeah so i'm curi i'm
actually genuinely curious how close i
was in this game to
to to being able to take over yeah yeah
and i saw
um so i actually saw you play two like
slower games today
yep um but this is the first game that
you sent
and i'll say i i really liked the way
you played in the opening and
i i did catch part of your your session
with gotham chess
right with lavi and i think this is this
is a very
nice opening choice where it was easy
for you to kind of
get the initial setup where white's
piece is harmonized very well
um and by the time like already by here
like you completed development
uh you put pressure on this pawn on e5
and then your opponents played a very
natural looking move bishop g4
like hitting your knights and it seemed
like this move allowed black to kind of
hold on to the pawn because the knights
pinned but it turned out you had a
really nice way to punish black
for playing bishop g4 here
and um i think what you played in the
game f5
this is still logical and this kind of
still went along with kind of the middle
game strategy kind of get this nice pawn
chain
and then unleash your your dark squared
vision well interestingly
when i played this i remember that
it was my instinct to play it during my
lesson
with levy and he pointed out it was not
actually the best thing to play i just
couldn't remember what we ended up
deciding was the best thing to play
yeah yeah so a move like f5 there's
times where
it's very good and there's times where
you do want to leave the tension between
the pawns
then there's also times where you want
to to capture on e5
and i'll go ahead and say here that you
should capture first on e5
because there's a very nice kind of
tactical combination
and i know levy has this kind of saying
you should always be looking
for checks captures and attacks
and if you apply that kind of process in
this position
what's what's like one of the most
forcing moves that you
you should consider here well if i take
the pawn on f7
i'm guessing the king will take back
although it doesn't have to
that's true if it doesn't take back then
you're happy to just win the pawn and
take away boxcasting rights
sure um but yeah bishop f7 is the most
forcing move
and even if you maybe doubt the move
could could be good
sometimes you want to look one extra
move further so let's imagine you take
on a seven king takes f7
yep uh what move can you follow up with
which would be
incredibly strong i could do knight to
e5
check and then i can take the
bishop exactly yeah and and this is
probably what would have happened if if
you went into this line
after takes takes you temporarily
sacrifice a bishop
however after 95 you're you're reading
back
the bishop on g4 yep you're destroying
the black king side
uh black has to move the king let's say
king to g8
you take the bishop and then if we count
material here
you're you're up two pawns right with
just a great position you have the
center pawns
black lost casting rights um
so even like early in the opening you do
want to be tactically alert
and if you continue to play this opening
this is actually a very typical idea
when the bishop comes to g4 that you can
you can employ like these tactics
especially when the queen's aligned with
the vision
so this is essentially just a
memorization thing because this is early
enough
in in this opening that i should be able
to spot this situation and know the
tactic
yeah yeah it's um it's definitely
something you could commit to memory
but even if let's say you somehow forget
it if you just ask yourself
what the forcing moves are if you see
the target on f7 you see the target on
g4
and you start looking for the forcing
move sometimes you can figure it out
um even if you do forget to forget right
exact
move order um
so what black should have done in this
position instead of bishop g4 was just
knight c6
like defending the pawn and then this
would be a case where f5
is actually a nice move right and um
yeah f5 is nice here because you block
the bishop and this bishop is actually
just kind of a depressed piece because i
can't develop actively
yep uh but going forward
you you play that five and then
uh then the game continued yes
and then then in this position it seemed
like you just didn't know what to do and
you
played a really bizarre move
so i i wanted to get a sense of your
thought process like what led you to
playing d3 here
um i'm not totally i can't really tell
you at the time i mean at the time i
don't know exactly what i was thinking
um i think the maybe my idea was
i don't yet know if and in which
direction black's going to castle
and absent any other ideas i mean i
guess i
considered playing um h3
but then i i wasn't really that
interested in trading on
f3 so it didn't seem like
really the right way to go so i sort of
thought of it as a waiting move
that maybe doesn't do any damage gotcha
yeah and like in in the game you played
b3
and continue with bishop e2 so maybe it
was just your plan
of like just developing uh your bishop
to this
so-called fiance square yes um
the big problem with b3 is that it's
very
kind of unkind to this bishop on c4
and you're leaving your knight
undefended on on c3
and i believe that that bishop ended up
getting stuck right
um later in the game yeah later on like
it just doesn't have the same mobility
yep and like this is a great diagonal
for the bishop
so sometimes what you do in these
positions
is you play a move um like a3
to give the bishop a square to retreat
to and also expand with b4
right this is a bit more um a bit more
harmonious
for white setup yep um but yeah like
it's
when we start searching for other moves
in in this position
you would really like to compete
development but it's not easy to do you
can't castle because the bishop's
controlling g1
and your knight's pinned on f3 you can't
develop your bishop to e3 because this
bishop is
uh is targeting the square
um so the other idea at the time was
bishop to d2
yeah so bishop d2 it's another kind of
passive move and doesn't
it brings out a bishop but doesn't
really help you in any way right
um so i would probably like if i was
white here
i'd consider a couple moves one is h3 oh
interesting
where you just want to force a trade of
of uh bishop for knights where you get
the bishop pair essentially takes takes
would be most expected
if the bishop moves to h5 what would you
do here
well often in these positions then i
just keep going well actually in this
case i think i would
i would definitely play g4 because i
think it traps the bishop
sometimes i will i will do this even
when i'm not trapping the bishop
but in this particular case it's more
obvious yeah and that's the great thing
about this opening like when you have
the pawn that f5
it's much easier to trap the bishop on
the king's side
right because the bishop just doesn't
have the square on g6
now one of the downsides with playing h3
is after takes takes there's this knight
t4 move
yep and then uh first of all what is
this attacking
uh it's attacking the queen and
threatening a fork on c2
so what would you do here to defend both
well f2 is bad because then well i guess
it's not really a problem
if with the fork on c2 then i can just
take
on c2 with the queen um
yes actually that's probably what i
would do yeah so queen f2 is actually a
mistake
you did identify like one nice thing if
takes takes
this is good for you the problem when
you align
with uh the bishop like this you're
subjecting yourself to
really any knight move will attack your
queen right uh so black has a stronger
move here knight b3
which attacks your queen and you're
losing your rook at least right
right so i would be better off on
developing the queen
back today yeah back to d1 and it's not
so pretty but the idea would be to
continue with bishop e3 here
yep and the game goes on your queen
probably redevelops to d2
and uh maybe later you can play g4 too
and get some nice uh
nice structure on the king's side yep um
well let's go back let's see what
happened in your game
because b3 like it was it was probably a
positional mistake
but you're not losing any material
because of this
and you did complete development and
this was actually very nice for you you
were able to castle
because that moved off this this
diagonal yep
um and then if we keep going
[Music]
i um yeah overall i i didn't mind how
you played like this this middle game
um a3 was a slightly mysterious move
to me too yeah where it seemed like
i've seen so i watched your most recent
at least part of your most recent
uh david patman arena okay and i would
notice this in some of your games
especially
like if you were getting low on time you
just play this like this random rook
pawn move
right when you weren't sure what to do
um
which isn't always a bad thing like in
this case it's not a blunder but there's
more useful things you can do in the
position
and usually like when you're completed
with development and um
you're entering the middle game you want
to look for ways to further improve your
pieces
um so a3 doesn't really help improve
like any of your minor pieces
and there's pieces that could find
better squares
as white in this position like your rook
on a1 is not doing anything
your queen is also a little bit uh was
just sitting there doing nothing just
in in the face of the the pin um
so one move to consider here is just
queen d2
where you get out of the pin your
knight's still defended twice
so you're not losing the material and
then your rook can enter the center
yeah i think this situation is really
where my vision is limited where i
rarely see
these one square queen moves as being
that useful to me so it just
my instinct is it there's probably
something better
gotcha yeah so actually these like these
one square queen moves are very typical
in the middle game because it's a way to
get your rooks connected
when the rooks are connected then it can
lead to um
to easier play further down the road
like if files open up then
your rooks have have a bit more a bit
more options later on
got it in this position because like the
the
position so closed it's not so relevant
but um that queen d2 is still probably a
bit more useful than a3
okay um however when you do play a3 you
are maybe preparing b4
and then your bishop has a bit more
scope right so it wasn't bad
uh takes takes bishop h3
and then here now here this i remember
this is the first move where i started
thinking more about
a few moves ahead in different scenarios
and in fact i considered rook to g1
and then rook to f2 and i just gave away
the rook by putting it
on g1 when clearly f2 or i'm sorry no
either way i would be giving away the
rook there no so
bishop is controlling both squares yeah
uh okay so in fact
both moves i considered just give away
the rook right
so yeah there's actually one safe rook
move you could play here
uh to e1 to e1 and
uh this would enable you to save the
rook and um and
not lose any material right black does
have this
bishop f2 but your rook rook is always
going to have us to stay square
this probably would have been the best
round yeah
so i assume when you played rook g1 you
just didn't see the the danger of the
exactly right and these are the types of
mistakes like you really want to try and
fix
where like you definitely don't want to
give
give away free stuff when it's not not
necessary
certainly and the way to try and fix
that is
before you make a move to try and
visualize the move
that you want to play and ask yourself
like what can the opponent do to punish
me
sure you always want to be thinking kind
of worst case scenario so if you
visualize rook g1 and ask yourself like
what can block do
you'd be more likely to see bishop takes
gmo yeah
um interestingly enough this this turned
out to be a fascinating
sacrifice right because essentially
black traded off one of the best pieces
and then this bishop kind of got stuck
on h3 and you're already threatening
queen g3 to trap the bishop
right so some sort of like accidental
brilliance on your part
i mean i was certainly thinking
proactively about launching an attack
on this side nice yeah which is very
typical like
this is your whole plan from the very
beginning of the opening
to get this pawn chain to get the
kingside attack and
it almost paid off like if we go forward
and see what happened in the game
uh this was actually a very good move
from your opponent not h5
has it defended the pawn it prevented
you from playing queen g3
yep uh you proceeded bishop d5
yeah unfortunately i know you wanted to
be aggressive
unfortunately this didn't really beat so
much yeah i realized when i did this
that this was this was a bad idea there
was
you know i could have i mean i was
actually thinking here about bishop
to c1 to start getting aligned over to
that side but i didn't want to block my
rook in
at this point yeah fair enough
um yeah it's not the easiest position to
kind of figure out what to do is white
uh one move that i would consider is
92 basically to leave the bishop
on b2 and unleash it right and possibly
at some point play f4
interesting they're trying to remove
black's like mean center pawn
and then like this is the uh the power
of the bishop along the long diagonal is
it if the diagonal opens up then the
bishop can be a very very powerful piece
right um but okay what happened the game
yeah your bishop did did get stuck yep
oh and now i'm realizing oh this is
actually really funny
i guess i didn't realize this uh before
looking at the game
your opponent actually induced you to
playing
the best tactical combination and i
think this is where i actually realized
it and thought hey i have something here
and my chat was probably screaming at me
to suggest this move
in this position bishop bishop takes s7
could be played right away
yep it's way better than 92 and yeah
this goes back to like the
checks captures attacks like look for
the forcing moves and then if you
calculate one move ahead
you're picking up the knights and then
on top of that you're trapping the
bishop
and so this at this point i made a
couple of the best moves in a row
uh yeah starting with bishop f7 right um
which yeah i guess you still had this f7
there
but uh it's really funny like your
opponent
a few times in this game it seemed like
your opponent was the one
um victimizing you but then you you had
this kind of unexpected
uh resourcefulness
and it led to like just a great position
for you because you're picking up the
bishop
um yeah bishop sacrifice itself now
in this bit was it right to take with
the pawn there
it's an interesting decision i think
queen or pawn takes is
is perfectly fine okay i i do like pawn
takes because
you can more easily use this pawn as a
weapon
that was at the right moment play f6
yeah and actually later on in the game
you had an opportunity where this move
could have been very strong
so at this point am i am i ahead
yeah so if we count material it's a bit
imbalanced
so both sides have the same number of
pawns
um the main difference is you have two
minor pieces knight in bishop
your opponent has a rook for it yep in
general
two minor pieces are much preferable
over a rook
even the rook and the pawn two minor
pieces are still usually preferable
because they can be more active in in
the middle game
um sometimes rooks can be a bit more
useful in endgame
but in this position like the rooks are
just doing nothing for black yeah
and united bishop have a lot more
potential
now your main mistake in this game was
not using your knight in bishop like
soon enough
right if we go forward between d6 rook
g1 i like the way you played this
so rook g1 is okay rook g wants the best
move by far ah
wow because you um this is one of the
only
files that you don't have a pawn on
black has a pawn in it so we call it a
half open file sure
but um it's usually a good idea
not only to put your rooks on open files
or half open files
but usually to align your rooks with
opponent's king
and um when you play rook g1 you're
already probably already thinking about
mating on g7
yeah you can get the queen queen in or
even get the pawn
and i'm looking at the fact that my
bishop if i could get it involved is
aligned
sort of with where i would want it yeah
so your bishop
um this is what we call x-ray vision
where your bishop is not staring
directly at g7
but there's potential right and uh if we
go forward one more
move your pawn play queen c1
now i think what was going through my
head here was
i was so thinking that i was winning
that i was basically like
i don't even care about the pawn on c2
this is a huge and very common mistake
in chess and this happens to everyone
even the best players in the world
when they get a position that they think
is easily winning they start to relax
and that causes them to make more
mistakes
and and sometimes just let their whole
advantage slip right
um now on the flip side of that if
you're ever in like a dead losing
position this is why you should never
give up
right because you should know sometimes
your opponent might not
be looking so closely at the dangers
and in fact i thought here about
f6 but eventually didn't play it
and i'm wondering if maybe this is when
it started to go bad
yeah so you you played an interesting
move like you played an attacking move
but um f6 is just so much stronger
is it okay because when you play f6
you're you're threatening
you're actually threatening force
checkmates
let's imagine queen takes c2 how would
you finish off the game here
um
is it do i do i take the pawn with the
rook on g7
and black has one legal move king
athletes right
and then i guess queen to f7 we have
seven
yeah yeah so this is your whole
intention
right when you play f6 and you know at
one point i
i don't know if it was at this point or
one move forward
i started actually calculating and
saying okay
this position means the king has only
basically this square
and then i think it was actually
probably a move a move or two later so
we i'll let you know when that happens
but in any point case at this point
i think i started to make some
miscalculations
right right you you played bishop c1 now
just to address if you did play f6
yeah black can still defend with rook h7
and it still takes a bit more work um
but
usually when you have a situation like
this when you have um when you're the
one attacking
and making the threats you just want to
bring in as many pieces as possible
right and and keep making threats
um so i'll just go ahead and show you a
nice move here would be knight before
where you're bringing your knight closer
to the king side you're you're hitting
the pawn
you're reinforcing f6 or there's some
cases where you like
come into f6 on top of all of this
you're also attacking the queen
right and um
just to show you one example line like
let's say queen takes c2
you're really not worried about the
queen side you're just more concerned
about finishing things off on the king
side
yeah and here you can you can take on g7
uh because you're threatening made in
one and knight f6
is pretty much unstoppable right
so this could have uh this could have
been a very nice finish
this could have all gone differently
yeah
this is a the brutal thing about chess
like you can work work very hard to kind
of build up your position
get get a crushing attack but then even
like one or two missteps
and it can it can change the whole
result of the game
yep um no i think black
played rook to h7 anyway right
so defending g7 but you got the move
that you wanted to play bishop h6
it's still looking good for you okay you
lost c2
and you got an f6 so you're just going
full force here
now in this position was f6 the right
move
um i i do like f6 yeah
um though
honestly if if it was my decision
i would be more inclined to play 94.
ah okay it's one of these positions
where probably like a lot of moves are
winning
but 94 it just it's adding more fuel to
the fire
yeah where the threats uh is very clear
knight f6
and you're not even giving black the
option of taking your knights
right um yeah and then you have just so
many attackers
queen and rook are out of play so
there's another moment where if you
played this you probably would have won
the game
right uh queen takes d3 was played
and then we're approaching a situation
where you took on g7
and this was really tragic because like
oh yeah of course like you're you're
just focused on on destroying the black
king
and there's this concept in chess which
i i'm it
affects everyone it's called tunnel
vision right where you're so focused on
just
beating your opponent you forget about
your own your own issues
and here i mean rook takes g7 it's a
forcing move
unfortunately after you take back again
you're not putting back in check you
give back one more move you get me yeah
and then there it is so basically even
up to
um where where was where i really
went wrong where it was like
irreversible so
even in this position you should still
you're still
looking very good yeah um
i think i want to pose a question to you
like let's say you have this position
again
um of course now you're aware if you
take on g7
yeah you're you're leaving your king
exposed on the back ring
yep so what can white play differently
that that gives better chances
to to actually win the game i mean would
i still take the pawn but with either my
pawn or the bishop
so uh first things first if you take
with the bishop
you're you're losing the queen yeah so
that's not good and you know what
that that actually i did go through that
process and realized in the game that
that's off the table for that particular
reason so would i take with the pawn
maybe
so taking with pawn uh looks like a
completely fine move
now i actually so i'll admit i have not
checked the game with engine and this is
actually
a somewhat complex position because it's
still
it's still a question how you finish off
the attack yeah but i'm pretty sure
you're winning here
if we imagine black takes a knight
um i mean you have the pawn on the
seventh ring you have your your bishop
queen and rook
all kind of set up very nicely
but how to how to i'm not actually sure
what move i position
so yeah if we go through like checks and
captures
you don't have any checks or any
captures that make sense in this
position your only
possible checks are queen checks those
don't lead to anything
um and then we want to think about
attacks
and one very common type of like forcing
move
that isn't isn't a check it's not a
capture
um but it's a basically it's a meat
threat so how can you play a move to
threaten checkmate in one
to threaten checkmate right uh
another way to think about this is
imagine you can put your queen anywhere
on the board
on what square can you put your queen
where it's chuck news
uh wow i'm actually unsure uh
oh um wait a second g6
um no oh g6 is in check
but am i looking for a check here
so you're looking for the the most ideal
square for your queen
even if it's like not a immediate legal
move
oh oh oh well i don't know like uh
f8 e8 or something i mean right now it
would be at risk because of the rook
right so the rook's covering the back
ranks so are there any other like
possible checking squares
like look along the diagonal e7
i'm sorry e6 e6 yeah so e6 is a square
that you actually
you want to try and get to and you also
brought up f8 which is defended by the
rook but if we imagine
like let's say your queen can get to f8
and the rook takes it yep you take back
yes and it's checkmate right oh wow
okay so the two squares that you you
want to look to get to are either f
or e6 and if you had so then that would
be f
queen f5 right exactly yeah and you're
actually threatening
these two moves and um
oh my gosh i thought this was winning
turns out that this might not be this
knife might not be winning because of
rook takes h6
defending the defending e6 square and
covering f8 wow
um so even when you you apply like all
this thought process and it goes back to
like the brutal
part about chess it's sometimes it can
be hard to finish off an attack
yeah um so one thing
now i wonder if in this position what
about
f7 yeah so f7 i was going to say is
probably
probably the go-to move where you you
keep
your your options open but it's still
complicated
and it's like even even just glancing at
this i'm not sure
if there's a clear win if we imagine
if we imagine king h8 oh right to move
checkmate in one will
um bishop to g7
yeah this is actually a really beautiful
checkmate because the rook's pinned
right
um and if king f8
then it might still take work
um
where if you take on g7
like the line i'm calculating is it's
quite deep bishop takes g7
rook takes g7 yep you deliver check
yep king goes back
and then you can take the rook yes you
can actually take either rook
but here's a case where your f3 pawn is
hanging
so if you take the rook on a you're
you're actually getting made it again
oh god so you'd probably want to take
this rook
but then there's queen takes f3 it's a
whole mess
it's a mess so i would imagine
your mistake came a bit earlier where
your knight was out of play like you
should have played 94 earlier
where it's best to avoid like this
really complicated situation
yeah um and we can always check with the
engine like where
like what the what stockfish would do to
to actually convert this position
yeah but from a practical point of view
you should
like when you're attacking you should
really try and um
and bring in as many pieces as possible
and be careful
of counter attacks as well so it was to
go back
right so this this would have been the
point where knight e4 would have just
changed the picture of
everything that happened after yeah
either knight e4
or um or f6 right away or f6 right away
yeah um but
i mean overall you you got you you put
yourself in a great situation
to to break through and it's
like these sort of moments of like
missing queen f1 names
are um they're painful moments but
they're they're
very important to learn from they're
instructive it's a teachable moment
yeah and if if you're like more alert
about what the opponent wants to do
especially when you're the one in the
driver's seat right then then you'll win
a lot more games
right you you won't be you won't be
blowing these positions
and then is there any earlier point
where there were some earlier moves
where you said you know this is okay
it doesn't really serve a purpose or
that's not hugely damaging but
like was there a particular other middle
game move where
i could have just changed the whole
shape of it in my favor well the the
opening trap or the the basically the
tactic we addressed
okay earliest yeah and this this goes
back to the point of why tactics are so
important
yeah where if you can find like the
right
tactical combination or ability just to
hold on to your pieces and not give any
anything away from free for free it will
make you a much stronger player
you know for whatever reason i don't
seem to be synced up with you anymore
oh um if you look below the board yeah
there are there's a green sync button or
there should be a sync button and a rack
button
and both of those should be green okay
no it was red
okay now i got it very okay yep now
we're good
yeah so like this position might be a
good one to review
of takes takes and bishop takes outside
yep
um and the great thing is that like all
of the analysis we're doing here
is saved so if you ever want to like go
back and look at this
or like toggle on stockfish and see
see like the crushing moves you could
play um it's all here for you to review
yep excellent
so i mean i think the reassuring part
about this one is
in a few different not trivial
situations
i found a couple of the best moves in a
row but then it imploded
yeah and it's like um kind of avoidable
mistakes
right where i noticed this with a lot of
your games
where yeah like you could have have a
nice position
or just a normal position where like one
tackle tactical mistake
or one simple oversight can cause you to
uh can cause a whole position to implode
right
and if you minimize these sort of things
then um
this is how you can get stronger
especially at your level
yep definitely definitely but it comes
with experience and this is why
like kind of leading up to this plot
champs tournaments
i recommend like try and try and play
serious games
on on a consistent basis and try and be
in like really good
kind of mental form and really focused
when you're playing uh these training
games
yes so when it when it comes to just
generally talking about the opening
i find that at this point no matter how
much preparation i try to do
on like the first five moves for
whatever i'm trying to do i'll
face some combination from my opponent
that i'm just not prepared for and then
all of a sudden
that's where i often end up making a
mistake and this is very typical that
at lower levels people are playing
complete like random stuff
and it's very hard to actually like be
be precisely prepared and this is why
it's more important to kind of
understand principles
if you're playing opening systems like
this is a great example where
you played this sort of uh vienna setup
or or if it's like a sicilian from black
it's called grand prix
but you have a general sense of where
your pieces should go
and there's a lot of ideas associated
with the setup where even if your
opponent does something
differently you can still
use hopefully we'll still have kind of a
toolbox of different ideas
too to figure out
um but then like and this is the thing
about chess most of the chess game
you'll be
on your own right and the vast majority
of your games will not be determined in
the opening
so you should probably put more energy
into like
these middle game strategy and tactical
moments so for the opening i should try
to avoid
immediately falling behind rather than
memorizing endless positions yeah i mean
it's okay
it's completely okay to um to understand
uh basically a simple repertoire of
setups
that you want to employ and and look
into like the most common
move or common kind of uh variations
that you'll run into
um but it'll only get you so far
yeah so were there any openings that you
that you wanted to like ask about uh
from from either color well i mean
right now i really need to think about
what my strategy is going to be as black
for opening i mean
sure for white it's like you know i have
some thoughts on
i have some training on vienna i have
some on ponziani
etc but as black you know i
one one idea i'm thinking of is black
except again it gets to what you said
where
you know and all of a sudden i've got
naredinsky watching my streams
um is that i've been thinking of um
king's indian because it's feels
relatively straightforward with just a
couple of exceptions from white
and so from a memorization standpoint it
seems maybe favorable but again you know
next thing i know who knows who is uh
feeding the moves to whoever and then i
just i have someone very prepared
right right and um i mean this is where
i can try and come in
and give you some some recommendations
um when you say king's indian um
this usually refers to an opening you
play against d4
yes where you you employ the setup
knight f6
g6 bishop g7 castling i've seen your
online games and you
there's a lot of games where you just do
this against anything right well that's
that's question one which is if i see e4
do i just abandon this idea altogether
so when you play against e4 you can't
quite
play a typical king's indian okay
um and i'll show you why um
like we can use this game as an example
just in the opening this is a game i
think you played earlier today
on chess.com and you
you played kind of the the typical kings
indian celeb
the problem with doing this is you can
get hit with e5
right and frequently i do yeah not
everyone will punish you but some people
will punish you
yeah um anyone who nerd ski coaches will
punish you and you just don't want to
subject yourself to
such kind of cruelty um so if you wanted
to still play
something that's like that kind of
resembles the king's indian you can play
what's called
uh the modern or the pierce which
usually involves g6
important move to include to uh to
discourage e5
and then whatever white does then you
continue development
and you can kind of live happily without
worrying about e5
and the event of e5 you just take it so
the the most relevant modification
would be that i'm i'm inserting d6
exactly before i move the knight out
okay right
now i i would still
um i was actually thinking about this uh
before
our call in terms of like what openings
i can recommend that would that would
offer you some more comfort and that
would still be
simple to learn because even when you
play like um
a modder in your appearance and you play
d6 you're basically giving white the
entire
center yes and
it's kind of i mean it's playable
there's still
like high level players that will do
this but it's not the most pleasant
thing
to just give white the entire uh entire
kind of pawn center
and for you to play with less space now
what about d6 e5
so d6 e5 it's um
it's also playable there is a name for
this it's uh it's a fill door
sometimes players will play e5 first and
then d6 right
um it still has kind of a passive
reputation because you're you're
blocking in this bishop
right um probably what i would
recommend against e4 it's it still
resembles
kind of a appears or modern but it's a
little bit more aggressive
okay and it's to start actually with the
sicilian
you start with c5 because you're
discouraging white from playing d4
and then your general plan um will be
what's called the dragon uh the dragon
variation
which i don't know if you've heard of
before but it's one of the most common
defenses in chess
now let me ask and this we may get a
conflict here
levy rosman says do not play the
sicilian as black
until you were raided 2000. and i'm like
still a few months short of that
yeah um that's actually funny um
i i have a vague memory of him saying
that
but yeah this is probably just a
coaching
like a difference in coaching philosophy
yeah and this will also kind of go back
to
the point that we shouldn't spend so
much time in openings
right but we should at least give you a
starting point
of something simple to play yeah my goal
is
not to get tripped up early right and
not even have a reasonable shot at the
middle game because of some big mistake
in the first five or six moves
definitely um so the reason why i would
recommend the dragon and i i would
imagine like if i talked to levy
this would be some compromise because
out of when you say sicilian
this could include over a dozen
different variations
like sicilian it's a very it's a vast
kind of
very flexible opening um but i would
make the argument that the dragon
variation
is the simplest to learn for beginners
okay because it employs
it basically includes c5 and employs the
same setup
that you see in a king's indian or ah
okay
but it's a it's a little bit more
comfortable because you're um like
whenever white plays d4 you just take it
okay um it still takes some
some experience and uh some knowledge
but i think based on like your
competition especially in pot champs
it's an opening that you can get by with
it's very solid
and you're going to have like a very
safe king and and more kind of
aggressive potential in the middle game
okay that's interesting to me yeah
i i can show you like how a typical sort
of sicilian variation would go
for a dragon variation um many times
white will try and get in the move d4
uh usually starting with knight f3 okay
we should note if white plays d4
immediately
i'm just going to give you a hard rule
whenever white plays d4
you should take the pawn got it so um
if i plays d4 immediately you take the
pawn if the queen ever lands on d4
you immediately attack with knight c6
okay
um and then you you gain time chase away
the queen develop a knight
and then once the queen goes away i
start my sort of king's indian setup on
the left
yes so if the queen moves over then you
can
you can go you're familiar with the term
fiance
right oh yeah very much so intimately
familiar very good yeah because this is
uh
i guess this is what you did even even
when it wasn't so good in that
uh you looked at but uh
yeah you you just go for the fiance
setup and uh in this case the knight
prevents white from
from going to e5 but usually you include
this move as well
more often white will play knight f3
okay
um now here i recommend starting with d6
and the idea is you want to play knight
f6
but you don't want to run into this move
right and that's the purpose of d6
exactly and now now you're ready to
uh to employ your seller let's imagine
white plays d4
yep i take right exactly boom takes
and now knight has six yep and you go
for g6
bishop g7 and castling got it um
and very often when you play the dragon
you're
you're looking to develop the king side
before you you really touch anything on
the queen side
now with knight six you attack the pawn
usually white defends
you go for g6 and almost always your
next two moves will be
bishop g7 and castling and it's from
this position where white has like a
variety of different setups
but most often you can stick with
with bishop g7 castling later knight c6
and it's you get the position where your
pieces are on on nice squares
you have some nice pressure against the
center you have two center pawns white
only has one center pawn
um you have this half open c file which
more long term sometimes you'll you'll
develop your bishop and then get a rook
to
to the c file um
and i'd say the best way to learn this
is just by playing it
now it theoretically at least in this
position
where is the ideal place for the light
squared bishop
yeah for the lightsweight bishop um
there's a few different
setups light will will go for usually
the boss i'm sorry i meant for my light
squared mission
oh for your oh yeah um so this bishop is
actually the last piece
you look to develop in this variation
because
right off the bat it doesn't have a
great square right um
like if it ever goes to g4 white can
easily play f3
so very often it will kind of hold back
and just go to d7 okay that's typically
where i end up with it
in these positions or sometimes i'll go
for b7 if i think that there's some
advantage to it
that's also an idea yeah and there's
cases like later on in the middle game
let's say white plays like a very kind
of simple set of bishop e2 bishop g7
castle and castling um there is times
where you'll
go for a6 and b5 and the bishop can can
land it
on on the queen side fiend caddo yeah
and then then you have two bishops kind
of piercing through the center
influencing all four center squares got
it
um but i don't know if i want to dig
like too deep into like specific opening
theory but
if you understand kind of the main setup
the reason why you play d6 the reason
why you start with c5
i think this will offer you perhaps a
bit more comfort
than what you've been doing as black
yeah so to run it back this approach
would generally
be um i'm playing c5
followed by d6 taking on
d4 at any point where that point comes
forward
if the queen then recaptures i
immediately play knight to c6
and then as possible depending on what
white does
i develop the king's indian setup on the
left uh
eventually develop the the
b8 knight to c6 and then figure out what
the
what makes sense for my light squared
bishop exactly
yeah and i i think that will offer yeah
as i said that will offer us just some
more uh more pleasant positions um
rather than than having just the space
deficit from moving on
and then in terms of a6 and b5 i would
go to that
if what happens yeah so
then it really depends and that's like
when i
mentioned a6b5 that's like one
middle game idea to add to your toolbox
okay
that would not be i wouldn't replace
some of these earlier moves with that
it would just be for later on for later
on yeah like if you're not sure what to
do
rather than playing just some random
random move that you just don't have a
purpose for
yeah it's always good to look for look
for ideas that improve your position
got it um and actually in this position
rather than starting with a6 usually
it's more typical to play knight c6 yeah
like the most natural square for the
knights
and then um
and then the game can can branch out in
many ways but like you at least you're
you're completing the opening
you're following principles and you're
not falling victim to
any tactics got it
so i know like usually uh when studying
openings is black
there's it's it's a bit more difficult
for a lot of players
because white is usually the one trying
to attack you
um early on and sometimes you're more on
the defensive
sure um now we should also address
uh if y plays d4 okay
because this is another move that you'll
run into a lot and this is where i'd
recommend that you stick with a king's
indian
okay um you can't really like c5 isn't
as strong here
yep because it allows light to just grab
the center even more
um so
i guess i'd like to ask you just as kind
of a quick test how would you play
king's indian
from this position um well i think
first i would go knight to f6
good then pawn then bishop exactly yeah
you play knight six to prevent like from
playing e4
right let's say c4
um g6 yeah and you should have
i just made you a contributor so you
should have ability to move the pieces
okay i'll play this
so i played my bishop right uh oh maybe
we got unsynced um
you see bishop g7 though right bishop g
yes i see i played it yeah so this is a
case where i could
i could grab the center and now i'm
curious what would you do here
um i think i would castle and then if i
need to i
would maybe undevelop the knight to e8
is that is that a terrible idea
that's actually so this idea is actually
it's been played at like very high
levels
um i wouldn't recommend it because it's
it's a bit ugly but passive yeah the
simpler approach is just to play d6
so sticking with the same delay castle
um let's say knight of three i think now
i castle now castling
let's say i'll just keep developing
oh i'm not seeing your move for whatever
i don't know why we keep getting
unsynced let's see
the buttons below the board should be
green yeah they're turning red and then
i'm clicking them and then they go green
again
oh that's strange um okay now i see
bishop to e2 yeah
and now the question is like what would
you play as black in this position
so i i mean i think i would
think about c5
or knight to d7 oh no actually i don't
want to do well if i do that i'm sort of
committing to eventually putting the
bishop on b7 which maybe i don't want to
do
i think i would look at either e5 no not
e5 i would probably look at c5
okay so you mentioned you mentioned a
bunch of moves here i just want to
identify like all the moves you
mentioned c5
you mentioned when you mentioned e5
right um it's funny like the move i
would recommend you rejected right away
which is e5
ah interesting um
and this is maybe something that's
different when you compare the king's
indian
to like the sicilian dragon in sicilian
dragon
you almost never play this move but here
you you play e5
with intention of trying to poke it
quite center
and um at first okay
there's kind of a a long tactical
sequence
where at first it looks like white has
two attackers right
black only has one defender sure so it
looks like white can win a pawn
however your pawn on e5 is
we we can call tactically defended by
the bishop
and we can see how this plays out let's
imagine my takes
yep you take that right
um now the queens are staring each other
to make things simple let's say white
takes your queen
you take back and white takes on
e5 yes so you just lost a pawn
uh however there is a move here
to uh to basically try and win the pawn
back
so i want to get the knight out of the
way
so that my bishop attacks
attacks uh the knight on the on e5
um if i take the pawn on e4 then we
trade knights there
i'm sorry we don't trade nights i lose
my knight but then i take a knight back
and that essentially wins back the pawn
right exactly yeah so
this is basically what enables you to
play e5 safely
is that you have this tactic and uh the
resulting position is actually pleasant
for black
because you have a nice open position
you have the rook on the open file
your bishops can enter and uh
there's not too much to worry about okay
um so if you know through e5 that would
be
that that would be already like a very
good start this is just a very typical
king's indian idea
um i can go maybe three like three moves
further i can give you just a
better sense of what to do in the middle
game okay um
very often white will castle here
and then rather than taking right away
you can apply more pressure
to this pawn on d4 with just a simple
developing move
now i bring the knight out to c6 exactly
okay
and you're trying to entice white to
take
if whatever it takes you're happy to
kind of get this
kind of simple position everything's
defended for you
um and if white plays d5
um this is actually a move that most
kings indian players look forward to
um even though playing king's indian is
black exactly
okay yeah um because even though white
gets more space
the structure is a bit more defined and
okay you're going to move your knight to
e7
and your plan going forward in the
middle game
is to remove this light from s6
sometimes back to e8 back to d7
and then go for f5 and then even later
f4
and this sort of structure it should
look very very similar
to the system you play as white
where you basically have this nice pawn
chain directed
towards your opponent's king now this is
like the absolute main line like if you
played good players
you'd be like to get this position um
but uh i think this would be nice like
if you ever get the structure
then just knowing about this this f5
idea we can imagine
if light plays a move like b4 um you can
even play knight h5 here
and you're going you're going for the
kingside attack where
um once you get the pawn to f4
of you you have a lot of attacking ideas
involving the pawn storm
and if white takes my pawn on f5 i take
back with my g
pawn and then later i push to f4
yeah so we can imagine like rookie one
let's say f5
uh white takes um you actually have a
pleasant choice here
but uh you could take really with with
either minor pieces
or with your pawn um
and then this is where kind of tactics
can can come into play
yeah so like one idea i would have here
would be
because i have the rook on f8 i might
like to at some point
have some kind of discovered attack with
the rook i can't easily get the pawn out
of the way but i could get the bishop or
knight so that might
push me to take with one of the minor
pieces instead of the pawn
yeah i think that's very good reasoning
um so so move like bishop f5
where you you basically develop your
your only undeveloped piece
um then then yeah you keep the file open
and that file can very often be used as
an attacking weapon yeah and this um
i mean this idea is reminiscent of what
you play as white
i i'm pretty sure levy showed you like
some similar concepts with
the rook having the the half open file
now is it relevant here
as a reason also not to take that pawn
with my g-pawn
that the g-pawn defends the knight on h5
yeah so this is where it could get
tactical um
because your knight's undefended and
this is something like you always want
to sense a danger
yeah i'm pretty sure here it's okay even
though
white has this battery directed towards
your knight
um if white word should try and exploit
this
let's say by moving the knight from f3
and taking the pawn
the nice thing for you you can take back
and then this knight is hanging
ah knight's also pinned to the rook and
if white goes for this
then you're actually attacking both
rooks oh yeah yeah so that's in my favor
that could very quickly just uh go very
bad for white
now i probably have to be realistic that
i'm not going to be seeing that far
ahead
in these games at at my level as we like
to say
um yeah so like most of what you you
should be concerned about is just like
searching for or scanning the position
for undefended pieces
looking for the forcing moves and if you
do that sometimes you you will be able
to
find some some more advanced
combinations
but um yeah there shouldn't be any
pressure for you to like play exactly
like the
the engine like recommendation every
move oh sure
usually you should err on the side of
caution and and just keep
keep the game controlled and keep your
keep your options open
right that that makes perfect sense okay
so can we briefly go back to the
beginning on this one
actually let me uh i'm going to make a
new chapter
and we'll just call it king's indian
and this will just be more of a test to
see if you you've internalized like move
order
and hopefully it saves properly first
with the knight
yep then pawn
okay so far i stick with my plan and
bishop
great
so now i play d6 very good yeah just
discouraging e5
yeah um let's imagine
let's imagine i play e5 just this is
kind of a test for you
how would you react so uh i think i take
great
i'll say takes okay and then here
um so is this the situation where we
said i would just
then oh no there's no pawn to win back
in this case so i don't know that that
makes sense
do i just move back to d7 here so
i want to pause for a moment and i want
you to like try and
or just see the big picture of what's
going on and what just changed in the
position
after the pawn took there's something
you you're
clearly seeing attacked but yeah the
queens are scaring each other
yeah very often if you can take your
opponent's queen before they take your
own queen
it's it's what you should do oh okay
that's actually i mean that's good
because sometimes in these
optional queen trade situations i'm
unsure really how to evaluate it
yeah and the reason for it here is when
you take on d1 white has to make some
concession
white either has to undevelop the knight
or take with the king and loose casting
rights
right and i still have counseling rights
right and then next move
then you can safely move the knight okay
there's actually a bonus tactic here if
the king takes
um you can you can play knight g4 and
hit hit both pawns
ah right and then you're winning a pawn
maybe if your opponent's really bad
they'll get four
i hope my opponent's that bad that's
right that's my strategy in fact
it's just really hard yeah uh okay
okay yep that makes sense so if the
queen if the defile becomes uh comes
open i'm black i take the queen
yeah and this is common like across any
opening like when
when there's a trade like this you
should immediately see the option
and uh and usually go for it okay but
but we're in agreement that eventually
i'm i'm moving the knight to d7
uh well unless accepted in that yeah
right
exactly um but okay more often white
will play a move like knight
knight f3 okay uh now i castle
and let's say there should be two okay
um so now
knight to c6
um it was a right right idea that you
want to
continue development um and it's not a
bad move but usually you should play e5
first
okay e5 first so yeah to really just
pressure the center
got it and um
if they are to take let's review this
uh okay so this one is where i take i'll
take your queen
excellent yeah and then this is what
we've reviewed earlier and um
i think here it's it's not necessarily
about just purely memorizing this it's
just about understanding the flow of the
variation
yeah and that you're winning the pawn
back when the knight lands on e5
right um so let's say a castle
um okay so i think now i develop the
knight and put pressure on d4
right and here
um yeah you're putting a lot of pressure
because you have two attackers but your
bishop is also
kind of applying extra pressure yeah so
more often than not white will play a
move like d5
mm-hmm um okay so i think here we said
i go back to e7 and let's say i play a
move
play a move like rookie one okay so this
is usually where i start to be
ambivalent about like are we now in the
middle game would we say
so now yeah you've castled you've you've
developed most of your pieces
and once you get the structure yeah
especially with these
like the center pawns for each color
this is where you should really look to
uh to expand on the king's side on the
king side okay so
um i mean i guess i might start thinking
about so i'd still be looking at my
bishop and maybe d7 for the bishop
or maybe thinking about h6 g5
um remember what we talked about earlier
because you there's one like pawn
there's one clear pawn move you want to
achieve
oh right okay so this is where i might
move this knight back
in order to open up here yeah okay and
yeah knight g7 is fine um
or h5 you said or h5 or e8 very often
like let's say you play move like 98
which is also completely fine yeah
you'll end up playing f5 and then
returning the knight back to f6
right and then you want to get an f4 and
you want to
continue building up your attack and
your p your pieces can
can get into the game um very very
nicely
right um i don't know if you'll ever if
you'll get the chance to uh get a lesson
from akaru
but hikaru's been known to play the
king's indian
at the highest levels and he routinely
will get positions like this
where he'll just destroy his opponent on
the king side um so it's an opening that
that's used at the highest levels and
like
even at your level it's still like
intuitive to play
right um and then perhaps going forward
i can recommend if if you like if you
type into youtube
nakamura kings indian yeah you'll find
analysis of like his best kings indian
games and
you'll get a sense of like how how the
middle game attack can unfold
and so to go really back to high level
again just so
i am understanding this is all if my
opponent plays d4
if my opponent opponent starts with e4
then i'm going with the other routine
so potentially this is all potentially
uh where i'm starting with
uh what what did we decide on that i'm
starting with um
c5 and d6 was it alien dragon
sicilian dragon yeah so i didn't quite
explain like usually when i teach this
to new students
i explain why they call it the dragon um
maybe we can review it just uh just real
briefly
do you remember what to do here is black
so i think it was here good
i take great
um and then now do i start sort of a
king's indian setup on the left
now you do yeah so you'll kind of see
the overlap of ideas
and the reason they call this a dragon i
i think is for two reasons
uh the main reason is that um this
bishop on g7 can later
breathe fire across the board like it's
a very powerful piece
yeah um this is also considered the head
of the dragon
got it though it's it's like a very
powerful kind of defensive setup very
difficult for white to actually crack
yeah it's sort of uh i mean i see it in
the same way that i see a bear when i
look at five stars in the sky it's sort
of a vague
vague dragon but i think i i think i
understand what you're saying yeah you
have to maybe hallucinate
uh a lot to see it but um
yeah if you can achieve the setup alexa
wanted to chime in there
oh wow um yeah if you can achieve this
you're not going to lose
in uh i sent a link to your phone with
instructions alexis stop it
that will happen every so often
apologies for that that's okay
uh okay so then at this point then i'm
trying to remember
am i now looking to bring my knight out
to c6 right knight c6
and um and really i gave you a starting
point
yeah um as you as you maybe play
this these openings and more games then
um
based on on what you're running into
that's where you you want to
um kind of expand your knowledge um but
uh yeah knight c6 very often the bishop
can come to d7
keep in mind this plan your book wants
to come to c8s
and you always want to be looking for
opportunities in the center
with your knight pressuring this pawn
your bishop pressuring the diagonal
so um yeah so hopefully this will be a
good starting point and can offer you
some
some interesting games and this will
hopefully not
really put me at a disadvantage if
someone were to
uh observe that i'm learning this
i don't think so yeah i mean there are
like weird tricky gambits
but i think like as
especially in preparation for a
tournament like pogchamps
you you want to you just want to build
up
kind of your um your your knowledge of
the openings that you're playing
right and then um and focus more on on
kind of
uh middle game strategy tactics and then
as the tournament uh gets closer then
it probably makes sense to prepare more
specifically for each opponent
right maybe to do so a bit more
secretively um
and i am aware that like you you do have
a few different weapons in your
repertoire apart from what we looked at
today
um from from when we we met a while ago
so you might bring back
some some uh some other weapons
um depending who you're playing and
depending
what is known about uh what they're
being taught
on right right and i should be deploying
opposition research on them exactly yeah
yeah um and that's something where like
i'm happy to help
or whatever coaches you're working with
should should also be doing um there
there's a website where
if you know anyone's lead chess username
or chess.com username you can plug in
their username and see
basically their whole game history what
openings are most likely to play
what they score with each opening
it's a very powerful tool it's called
openingtree.com and you can uh
i mean you can use it yourself but
that's what i use to
really do opposition research and this
is all it's not like when the patriots
were filming people
allegedly and stuff like that this is
all totally kosher
so it's all it's all public yeah there's
nothing
there's nothing against like preparing
deeply for someone before a game
yeah using whatever databases engine
analysis
um but during a game you're going to be
all on your own and that's where you
really have to
to just be in your top mental form
and and use kind of all the insights and
and strategies you've been working on
beautiful
beautiful well it's a lot to bear in
mind but i think
i think my goal is to have probably
three different ways i could go as white
to be less predictable and then
some options as black which it sounds
like it's what we're developing
where i can deal with the most common
openings that i would that i would uh
deal with and then i probably need some
general strategy
if white plays something wacky
sure and that's actually like if if
white does
like weird stuff like g3 or knight f3
um or c4 like there's a lot of like
first moves that we
it's hard to get to all of them um and
that's why king's indian
is like a a nice opening choice because
this is your general strategy
right um so even if you just remember
like these simple arrows for black that
will enable you to
meet most openings with like just a
solid approach that will just get you
into a middle game
where hopefully you can outplay your
opponents because you're better than
them
yeah absolutely absolutely uh
awesome okay i mean this is probably
good for me you know we're sort of a
at the limit of what i can remember but
i think the next step would be i should
review this tomorrow and then maybe
you know play one or two longer games
and try to apply some of this
oh definitely i mean the the best way
especially when it comes to openings and
just
in general like just chess strategies
the best way to learn is
is to just get experience in in longer
games
yeah and um yeah play try and play with
a growth mindset where
you're not too concerned with the result
you're just trying to
to learn something from every game and
um
and and take away a lesson from every
game so that by the po
by the time pogchamps comes around
you'll right you'll you'll have a lot
more uh
of knowledge to rely on and in terms of
using stockfish to see like what are the
best
computer moves after i've played a game
is
is that useful or do you think that's
not necessarily the most useful thing
um yeah this is actually that's a very
good question this is highly debated
where
you don't want to become so reliant on
stockfish where you just
have it turned on and it's spitting out
it's like always fitting out even like a
slightly better move than what you
played
yeah um it is good at identifying
like the key blunders that you've made
right um
beyond that like i and this applies like
on on both sides because on beaches and
chess.com
have tools where you can you can go
through and kind of get an engine report
of what happened with your your game and
we can even do this
like um if i wanted to do this for the
game that we went over
uh i think trust.com like you can do it
right after you finish a game
yeah on each house you can do it also
after you finish the game or in the
study
um people can see on my stream but
if you look below the
the board the request a computer
analysis thing yeah and i just click
that so it's gonna it's gonna
kind of crunch through all the moves
yeah and then show a breakdown
of your inaccuracies mistakes and
blunders
gotcha so i would say like the blunders
are the most relevant moments you should
look at
right um inaccuracies mistakes are
they're still
like useful to look at but but like
blunders will usually be like the
clearest moments where you can
take away some lesson yeah it's
certainly pointing out that uh
the the f5 moment we talked about where
i should have taken on e5
yeah so that was a missed opportunity
you didn't really blunder away anything
but you missed the opportunity to win
material
um and then we have the b3 which was
just kind of a
weird waiting move um saying yeah bishop
to b5 was best
yeah um actually so b3 i'm slightly
surprised
it's it's like a full blunder because i
thought that would be more of an
inaccuracy but yeah uh maybe it was just
such a bad positional move that's
right then of course when i gave away
the rook that was certainly a blunder
exactly yeah yeah and then actually that
was it the rest were
inaccuracies uh well up until the
end where something terrible happened
uh i think when oh i see oh i'm not even
getting i don't have the end of the game
here for whatever reason it didn't
i think it was still still crunching
through the the i see
we also we did so much analysis that the
main line kind of got buried
oh i gotcha oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a whole scene yeah i see what
you're saying now
right yeah so and you can also like turn
on stockfish to kind of get a quick
feedback
but i would say like you should be
hesitant when
when just having it on you should really
try and understand the position
on your own instead of letting the
computer just spit out like the
evaluation
and the moves got it that makes sense
that makes sense
all right my friend uh thank you so much
of extremely informative
yeah no it's been great um i hope i hope
people watching and enjoy this
and happy to stay in touch if you have
any questions just
just feel free to uh to reach out oh i
will there i certainly will and um we
will
my youtube audience will will be
introduced to you on my channel tomorrow
ah oh for the next year so you stream
this on twitch and you're putting
yeah sometimes i'll do like multi
streams
but and that stuff i don't later post
but
i've been trying with these posting them
later to youtube and hitting a totally
different audience and i mean
you know we all have our ideas of what
what works best and what doesn't and
no one truly knows it's usually a matter
of experimentation
that's that's exactly right but it's see
i mean your youtube channel seems to be
doing beautifully
well i've been i've been a lot more
consistent recently than
even like last year yeah um and
yeah youtube has a lot more discovery
than twitch
where like twitch i'll do i'll do live
streams
um but then then i'll cut down and edit
the livestream
content for youtube and i did a poll the
other day i think
90 of my twitch audience found me
through youtube
oh that's huge that's hugely important
to know that yeah that's amazing
yeah that's incredible all right great
i'll be in touch then
sounds good okay great talk to you later
take care bye we'll see you
uh all right there it is uh eric rosen
incredibly informative incredibly
informative uh that's gonna do it for me
we have a we have such a huge day
tomorrow i wanna let you guys know for
people who are watching me on twitch
right now
tomorrow we have um what do we have
tomorrow
well i have a busy day but then we so
obviously we know about the tragedy of
the michael brooks situation
i addressed it at the top of this stream
and i'm going to talk about it more
tomorrow so
extremely sad and we're going to talk
about that
and then i i may have two or three
streams tomorrow
because there's a bunch of different
things going on so
that's going to do it for me but a lot a
lot a lot tomorrow
and i will see you guys then and let's
in fact since we are
on twitch let's raid eric rosen
and oh wait a second hold on
why am i unable to do that he seems to
still be streaming
subscriber only chat hold on a second
i'm following him why can't we raid eric
[Music]
i have a raid in progress oh here we go
okay what am i doing
what am i doing uh all right very good
all right thanks everybody from for
joining me
let's head over to eric's channel and
we'll see we'll be back with you guys
tomorrow